thaler ya teddy qui a parlé d'une soirée
entre doc gynéco et francesca et ils ont
dit qu'ils avaient été très proche d'une
soirée parce qu'ils ont chanté ensemble
c'était notre lors de notre première
soir en tunisie
j'ai emmené les chroniqueurs découvrir
la médina de hammamet et doc gynéco
puisque c'était aussi lui qui avait
gagné le bloc jobs il avait aussi gagné
une séance de massage c'est ce que vous
allez voir maintenant et doc gynéco je
peux vous dire il a kiffé sa tête il
était dans un spa il acquit regarder il
arriver en forme le soir
[Musique]
suivez moi s'il vous plaît voilà on est
arrivé ils se sont bien passées vous
pouvez rentrer votre peignoir s'il vous
plaît mais c'est du troc soir
[Musique]
je vais vous mettre un petit masque
je reviens dans le stand
[Musique]
pourquoi vous y aider
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]